foreign
[Music]
thanks for being here hope you're having
an awesome conference so you are in the
building Next Generation databases Cloud
spanner under the hood session I am
pratiba Surya devara I lead the spanner
engineering both for internal offering
and also the cloud offering
present the session with me I have Chris
Taylor
VP Google fellow one of the original
authors of the spanner paper it's a
privilege to present with him and I have
John Fisher who is head of engineering
for Google photos
thanks folks
okay during the course of next 45
minutes what we wanted to do is walk you
through what spanner is why we started
with spanner then Chris will walk us
through the technical details under the
hood on what makes spanner what it is
and then we'll have John walk through
how Google photos leverages spanner and
the end of it we should have about 10
minutes or so for Q a so I'd request all
of you to line up at the mic if you have
any questions if you run out of time all
three of us will be available outside so
we can have a chat after the after the
session
so let's start with what spanner was
so
in in 2009 as Google was one of the
early disruptors on reimagining how the
businesses should be done online we
actually faced four challenges one is
lack of horizontal scale two is the
frequent downtime the businesses had to
take three is the high operational tile
The Operators had to deal with and four
is a load developer productivity looking
at the systems we had at that time we
came up with a conclusion that we needed
to build a system like spanner that has
these distributed capabilities to kind
of take care of these challenges
interestingly these are the very similar
challenges that I hear from our external
customers today all of you as you're
building your businesses you're
disrupting whatever domains you are in
you face the same challenges around
you're reaching out to your customers in
different channels the scale at which
you're talking to your customers the
features that you're providing for to
your customer customers you run into the
same scale challenges you're actually
looking at the similar challenges around
operational tile and also the developer
productivity that you have and the last
piece is as you build these systems
manually operating these self-managing
them becomes very complicated at a
certain scale
so what we did was let's build a
database that our customers can trust
what do we mean by that I think spanner
database as it built provided the
highest availability in the industry
today it provides the horizontal scale
that you need it also has zero downtime
that you look for your businesses and
also a lot of your businesses in retail
and all need that zero downtime
especially in the environments you scale
so having that horizontal scale
capability is awesome
second we wanted to build a system that
you can innovate on right all the way
from leveraging your existing skills we
provide open interfaces like postgres
and also a lot of your businesses today
don't run just one type of workloads you
have transactional workloads you have
analytic needs the system and the
architecture that we built gives you
that environment where you can run
hybrid workloads last the third
primitive I want to talk about is the
productivity like a manage I talked
about earlier a fully managed spanner is
what we build for our customers so that
you can spend your time and your
developer productivity on what's
important for your business versus
managing this infrastructure
so with this kind of infrastructure that
we built this is where spanner is today
hugely adopted inside and outside of
Google today we have around 3 billion
QPS running on spanner 12 exabytes of
data under management and the customers
that we have starting internal with
Google all the way from ads to YouTube
to photos to Chrome to search to Android
to gpay and all the Google workspaces
Calendar Gmail maps all of that runs
under spanner today in addition inside
of Google Cloud all the control planes
for GCS gke IAM all of that is built on
spanner for our external customers
all the way from gaming to retail to
financial to health care to social media
to Transportation these are all the
external customers running on spanner
today
so we've built this amazing platform
that gives you the reliability the scale
the architecture the extensibility that
you need let me hand it over to Chris
he'll walk us to what we did to get to
this architecture
thank you hi my name is Chris Taylor and
I'm going to talk through the key pieces
of spanner and how they work together to
make spanner a great database for
applications that matter
really we start with scale
Clips are scary it's a failure at a
moment when something is something good
is happening to your business
and so we built spanner to handle handle
immense workloads
this was actually one of the easier
things that we did because Google at
that stage had lots of experience
building exabyte scale storage and key
value stores and a lot of that same DNA
is underneath spanner
um
along the way we were really careful to
make it work well for small users as
well we wanted this to be for Google's
workloads of all kinds and our customer
workloads of all kinds
and really it's amazing seeing our
customers feel safe knowing they're far
far Far From Any scale limit that we
have
in High availability was sort of the
next principle here we had all used hadr
implementations where you have a big
bang failover and it's kind of built as
an add-on you build the first system and
then you build a second one and you fail
over to it
the reality of the cloud in our
experience is that at scale failures are
small but frequent and a system that
routes around these transparently and
automatically works much better in
practice and so this is how we tried to
do spanner we added fine-grained tablet
level failover SQL queries that restart
when they hit bad machines and things of
that kind and as a result spanner
survive small medium and even large
problems with low impact
we also carefully designed our just
ordinary life cycle events schema
changes software upgrades these happen
fully online we have no notion of
Maintenance downtime
spanner also offers multi-region
capabilities and this this stems from
realizing that the leap from one region
to two or more is a big challenge for an
application
do you want to redesign with eventual
consistency in mind
do you want to have these rarely
exercised monolithic failovers with the
possibility of data loss
we aim to make geodiversity really as
easy as possible we built rpo0
replication which brings you an extra
nine of availability
and we have the option to add extra read
replicas near your customers for reduced
read latency
we also recognizing that you know not
every customer that needs multi-region
starts with multi-region we implemented
an upgrade from Regional spanner to
multi-region spanner that you can use
when you need it the transition is fully
managed and online so you can start
small and build up
another reality of working with big
production databases is that traffic
shifts are a reality
the usage of an application is hard to
predict your app changes the world
changes around you and a result as a
result the pattern of traffic to your
key spaces shift and often the way you
were sharded before is invalid a minute
later
so with spanner we built strong
insurance against those kinds of
problems both online scaling so you can
just add more nodes when you need to
handle more traffic
but also fast inter server load
balancing and key range splitting
and these capabilities combined can turn
most hot spots into non-events
really spanner handles it and you never
even realize it happened to you
many of these strengths come from
Spanish compute storage separation
we have one tier of servers that handles
your queries and another tier of servers
that stores your data called Colossus
and this lets us radically rebalance
read and write loads on the fly without
data copies it also means that when one
of your query servers is lost you've
only lost a small fraction of your cash
and you really don't even notice that
that this is happening
separately we have a lot of experience
building key value applications we've
done many of them we've seen how they
grow up
the first 80 of a key value application
is invariably easy and fun
it's a it's a friendly way to model
and it's easy to see how the basic
patterns of your application map
but it's very common in my experience
that the last 20 percent of that app
needs a few more things from the
database and this is where the long tail
of these work workarounds drives a lot
of the complexity in the application by
the time it's done it doesn't look as
simple as how it started
now Engineers including myself are very
creative almost anything can be made to
work if you try hard at it but what we
saw with spanner is a big opportunity to
make our customers more productive and
their apps simpler and more maintainable
so
I put a subset of the features on here
I won't walk through them all but many
spanner applications do stick to plain
vanilla key values and spanner handles
that very well if you don't need more
the base system can handle your key
value workload with good price
performance and good performance
but we do see that many apps start that
way and then eventually reach for a few
more capabilities from the tool bag
whether it's transactions or indexes or
a little bit of SQL or whatever
and we're constantly adding more here
we're working with our customers to
understand what their most common design
patterns are and where they're hurting
the most and we try to add features that
can really take that complexity and
bundle it into a beautiful package
a great example is something we've just
announced Cloud spanner data boost
many apps have fresh and valuable data
but it's locked away from analytics
because of fear of the impact of those
workloads on serving
we know we all know how this is commonly
dealt with there's ztl and extra copies
of data or dedicated analytics replicas
with data boost we have a third way
you can query spanner from bigquery or
data flow or the analytics system of
your choice with strong isolation and no
fixed costs
so really you're just paying for the
usage of your queries
and this is again a consequence of
compute storage separation we're able to
use an on-demand pool of query workers
to run your data boost query the moment
you get them again with no fixed costs
also because of this compute storage
separation we're often able to apply
more resources to your queries and run
them significantly faster through higher
parallelism
this is an exciting example of
a really common pattern needing to run
analytics on your operational data that
is more hands-off than ever
sort of wrapping up here
we're trying to build the most capable
scale out database in the world
and we're not doing it because every
customer needs every feature but because
when you start out you don't know what
you'll need by the time you arrive with
your customers and really land your work
and we want you to be ready for anything
and with that I'm going to hand back to
pratiba to show some of the ways Google
has benefited from its no compromise
database
continuing let me walk through some
examples of a little bit breadth first
look at how different applications and
services inside of Google use Banner
so like Chris mentioned the tenants that
we built spanner with enables all of
Google to run on spanners today like I
said before Google runs on spanner all
the way from Google applications like
Gmail YouTube calendar Maps ads photos
just to say a few
all the workspace applications
Gmail Drive calendar meet sheets docs
and all the Google control planes for
services like gke GCS IAM all of this
run on spanner today in addition we have
alphabet companies like waymo and verily
also run spanner
so let me walk through some use cases on
why spanner what motivated them and
where are they today let me start with
ads ads was initially built as a
self-managed MySQL workload
the scale to which they got became a
problem where the MySQL was not scaling
for them and also the frequent downtimes
that they had to do whether to upgrade
this stack or outages because of the
scale kind of became Revenue impacting
for them this is one of the first
applications we started working on
spanner so we worked with them very
closely at this point all of a lot of
ads use cases whether it's auctioning
whether it's
giving ads to the web pages or their
payment systems all of them run on
spanner it's been over a decade or so
since ads been is running on spanner
we've not seen a single downtime that is
revenue impacting with ads on spanner
so the second application I want to talk
to you about is YouTube YouTube is
another sharded MySQL which was built on
vitess they started running into
challenges where they're both the cost
of the infrastructure because each of
the applications they built whether it
is their music or streaming each of them
was built on different stacks and also
the downtime and the fragmented Storage
Solutions was becoming too expensive for
them and their initial architecture was
also built on the very challenging
architecture on lamp which was not
scaling them after a scaling for them
after a certain scale
so they started migration to spanner so
today they launched multiple products
like music kids shots TV on a single
infrastructure which is the most
replicated data set across multiple
regions which is giving them a very high
resource efficiency and operational
Simplicity this is also a helping them
transform large processing pipelines for
their business things like spam
filtering things like personalization
and stuff which gives them the strong
consistency they need across regions and
also the security and privacy and
compliance they need
moving on the next application I want to
talk to you about is Google pay Google
pay in India Google pays as you know a
mobile payment service used for in-app
in person and also online contactless
payments today Google pay serves around
hundreds of millions of customers doing
billions of transactions monthly what
was important for them was a low latency
and massive scale a lot of you in retail
know that the scale when for the events
like cyber Mondays black Fridays
Festival Seasons like Diwali in India is
where your infrastructure gets stressed
out and where your reputation whether
the system is scaling or not and how it
scales and how much preparation that
goes into it becomes very critical for
the infrastructure providers so gpay
today they're able to scale because of
the spanner infrastructure in addition
especially retail and Financial
customers have these regulations and
compliance so all of that is offloaded
by spanner for these customers
and another customer our own information
retrieval systems inside of Google it
this system started more for indexing
and serving the web pages but over time
it became a multi-tenant infrastructure
that's used for multiple corporas public
and private YouTube Gmail photos bunch
of these systems right these systems
don't at this point just live with
serving and indexing they have to
provide lot more differentiated features
so having spanner as this uniform
infrastructure gives them the
replication the resiliency the
redundancy they need and they're also
able to quickly iterate on the features
they need to build one of the
interesting things is because they've
merged all these into a single system
all the bespoke solutions become one and
the infrastructure Simplicity and
operational Simplicity is what we are
big is becoming simpler on top of it the
search capabilities on spanner gives
them a single place for them to do and
not only do serving but they're able to
do analytics and search and also this
opens up similarity search and AI use
cases for them
the one last use case I want to talk to
you about is Chronicle this is in our
security space Chronicle is a Google
Enterprise service where customers can
actually privately store analyze and
detect any of the risky behavior in
their Network or security Telemetry so
this system again is a single store they
use globally
analyzing
exabytes of data within sub seconds of
latency is what they get by using
spanner
with that I gave you a brief overview of
internal use cases across different
spectrums across different verticals
inside of Google let me hand it over to
John who will give us a much deeper look
at how Google photos uses spanner
thanks pratifah hey everyone I'm John
Fisher it's great to be here I'm a
senior director of engineering at Google
leading engineering for Google photos
so I'm sure many of you know but Google
photos is the home for your memories
um it's a photo storage sharing
reminiscing service that offers a
complete consumer user workflow across
devices so that users can automatically
backup organize edit search and
reminisce about their most precious
moments
and all those power all those are built
with ML and AI at its core
Google photos has a global user base
with over a billion monthly active users
and our Corpus size is over 4 trillion
photos and videos
and so photos needs a database that can
scale to that size
across a wide variety of read and write
patterns
and so for photos that database is
spanner and we store tens of petabytes
across dozens of geographies to serve
our users
let's look at the life of a photo as a
user captures it and goes up into our
systems
so a user captures the photo on their
device and will upload those photos into
our product if the user has the backup
feature enabled and of course backup is
one of our most popular features because
it enables users to have the trust and
peace of mind that their content is safe
and so backup happens in two phases
first we upload the actual bytes of the
media into our encrypted blob storage
and we use GCS for that
next we take we upload and encrypt the
metadata into spanner things like the XF
data from images the file name and other
product specific metadata
and so at that point we've got we've got
the content we've got it safely stored
and users trust us with that data and so
we take privacy and security reliability
incredibly seriously
so uploading the content and the
metadata into the spanner and GCS is
just the tip of the iceberg at that
point a whole bunch of asynchronous
processing kicks off and this is all of
our machine learning and all of our
inferencing
and all that processing is funneled
around spanner which is the hub for our
machine learning workflows
these machine learning feature machine
learning models power our features to
organize to enable search and
reminiscing
and latency is very important for us
that we can deliver these features to
our users shortly after upload
so let's take an example let's say that
I was out hiking the other day and
wanted to search for that photo of a
waterfall
and given that this is a presentation
with Google photos I had to include some
of my own photos as well so there's a
selection of my waterfalls
after a photo is uploaded to our system
we cue that photo up for various forms
of that offline image processing ml
inferencing that helps us label
understand and organize the user's media
into the library
we infer the semantic contents of an
upload and understand both at an
individual level but also at an
aggregate level about how that piece of
content fits into the overall Library
and to do that it involves many large
complex spanner queries
that happen concurrently with many other
reads and writes they're running on that
user so we have this asynchronous
processing meanwhile the user continues
to browse and share and edit within
their app and so having those different
read and write workflows happens
concurrently is a key part of the design
thing the design principles that spanner
enables here
so once we've done that in machine
learning processing
process those signals and those labels
we store them back into spanner and then
we index them into our Downstream
indexing system to enable for our search
our search use case
so we can find those photos of waterfall
so overall this is a reasonably
conceptually simple architecture of
uploading content into our our back end
storing in our our blob storage and our
our database and having some of that
asynchronous processing so overall it's
got a simple mental model but that's
really just the tip of the iceberg
because we have over hundreds of
binaries and microservices and processes
to deliver on our product goals
and all those microservices have
different access patterns that range
from small lookups to large data scans
with a variety of latency and
reliability requirements
spanner has met every requirement we've
had off the shelf it's been incredibly
flexible easy to use
especially given our massive scale
as an example we have a global user base
and users like to organize their content
into albums and share them with each
other
and so that type of cross user sharing
requires you know seamless real-time
sharing and spanners Global indexes help
us deliver on that goal
so I've walked you through a bit of the
system diagram of Google photos
and I wanted to kind of step back and
highlight a few of the guiding
principles that have carried us forward
as we interact with spanner
and I want to use kind of a fun silly
little castle metaphor to illustrate
some of that
and in case you're wondering yes the
castle is AI generated
so photos continues to use a single
unified database
to power our application and this is the
foundation of our Castle it's the rock
that we've built on and so despite our
large size and growth in both users
items and queries per second
we've been able to continue to sustain
on this single unified database
architecture
navigating through our global global
needs and that's yielded a simpler
development experience a more
maintainable architecture enabling us to
lean into microservices navigate and
manage our technical debt and support a
tight release cycle so many of the
principles that in the tenants that
Chris laid out earlier we've really seen
them flow through in in our usage of the
product
our next principle is around strong
consistency and high concurrency and so
these are the strong walls of our Castle
we have strict consistency and
concurrency needs and that makes sense
when you think about that mix of
workflows workloads I talked about the
asynchronous batch processing and the
interactive user reads and writes of the
the product having that happen together
concurrently as well as the cross user
nature of our product where users love
to share their content and having that
cross user consistency that's important
and so spanners high right throughput
and consistency guarantees Resource
Management tools allow photos to build
and scale these features and pipelines
by over 10x with minimal re-architecture
so we've really hit that goal of kind of
future proofing our further growth and
our database is user-centric
and we lean heavily on that asynchronous
processing for efficiency and latency
reasons
so overall we're able to kind of deliver
on all that
complexity of the hundreds of
microservices while still delivering on
our product goals
coming back to kind of the enabling of
those ml workflows data needs to flow in
and out of our Castle our data
we have that rich set of ml powered
features that rely on our ability to
understand the semantic content of a
user's content and their overall Library
and so again going back to that search
example we have a wide variety of
signals that we label each content
around and store all that information in
spanner
and using those signals in a variety of
other metadata we associate across these
contents within an account to determine
the most meaningful moments for a given
user
and all of this functionality requires
different database workloads we've built
a queuing system on top of spanner that
allows us to reliably process those
those work items and we for the search
example again we have a variety of scans
lookups Point lookups and joins at
search time
our memories feature which kind of has a
collection around a trip or a moment
requires large scans secondary indices
and additional tables with derived
metadata to power that
we also do clustering like clustering of
a thing or a person and those those
operations require us to look at all the
photos within a user's account combining
large scans and streaming approaches
so despite the wide variety of kind of
workloads and different needs here
spanner is able to meet all of this
completely off the shelf for us
I mentioned that privacy and security is
at our core
we really need to deliver on a user
expectation of trust privacy and
security
and that's the layer of protection
around our Castle
users store their most precious moments
with with us and so we want to ensure
that
data is encrypted at rest tightly Access
Control to protect against Bad actors
and unauthorized access and that the
security and privacy best practices are
kind of baked in from the core so we can
confidently execute on additional
features
and we care incredibly about reliability
as well and so we're confident that
users data is always available when they
need it with a variety of data Integrity
checks as well as backups for Disaster
Recovery
our final principle is around
operational excellence
and so we're proud of running a tight
ship on top of spanner and so we've got
our our flag on the castle flying high
there to celebrate that
spanner has significantly reduced our
toil we save a ton of time and energy on
tactical placement location distribution
sharding scaling redundancy backup
management all of the things that lets
us focus on delivering the value to our
users and not managing our
infrastructure
and so for replicas we input the specs
and spanner handle the change in
replication with adding and deleting
shards the self-healing nature of
spanner such as automated index
verifications charting draining
guaranteed data consistency across
regions it saves us a ton of work
and so we rely on spanner to
automatically replicate data with five
nines availability ensuring our users
are confident their data is always safe
and that same spanner sharding allows us
to roll out incrementally and observe
how changes perform which is a big win
for our reliability
so kind of wrapping up on the principles
you can see them around having a single
unified database
strong consistency and high concurrency
enabling our ml workflows private and
secure by default and operationally
excellent
all that has helped us deliver an
amazing product Google photos to see an
amazing success running on spanner and
the numbers speak them for themselves
with over a billion users over 4
trillion items in our Corpus spanners
plays a huge role operating at that
scale
photos has experienced 10x growth since
onboarding onto spanner and we're
confident that we can scale another 10x
and so it's really exciting what it's
allowed us to do and we can't wait to
continue bringing more amazing features
to all of our Google photos users thanks
back to pratiba to wrap us up
thanks John thanks for giving us a
breath look at what you do with photos
uh amazing partner for us hope during
the session you found what why spanner
what we did with spanner what we do with
spanner inside of Google and amazing
Partners like Google photos who leverage
spanners to grow their business and
Delight the customers
so I just want to leave you with
this the amazing experience that we give
with to our external customers our
internal customers as you're
transforming your businesses let B let
us be your partners let's work with you
to kind of bring your workloads on to no
compromise cloud cloud spanner with that
thanks for your time
[Applause]
foreign